people of the internet retro recontour
here welcome back to harry potter
quidditch world cup
it's team usa versus germany here today
guys welcome back to our let's play
series for harry potter
and the quidditch world cup this is our
second game
in the world cup mode it's been very
easy up to this point
but i've heard that things are going to
get a lot harder so we're going to try
to pull off some combos here
[Applause]
[Music]
oh yeah debbie montz
i forgot i love how they they have all
the names by the way we're trying uh no
webcam today so
let me guys know what you think yeah i
found some people prefer the webcam and
some people prefer not to have a webcam
so let me know if you guys have a
preference or if you don't mind either
way i thought we'd give this a shot
certainly gives it a little bit more
screen real estate you don't have
anything at all covering up the screen
which it's not too big of a problem with
this game but there are some games where
you know it can block important parts of
the screen here so we're off to a 20 to
nothing lead right now
oh no oh no they're getting close
they're getting close we gotta go for a
steal
no
okay i definitely uh feel a little bit
of an increase in difficulty
oh yeah
and i totally just did not even expect
it
i didn't even know what was happening
yeah the combo system is really kind of
confusing
it really is
oh yeah
i feel like a lot of times i feel like i
should be close enough to take a shot
but i'm actually not by the way i know
some of you have been asking about the
future of the harry potter games on the
channel like let's plays
uh those are definitely coming back i
mean i consider this a harry potter game
as well but i think a lot of folks are
ready for me to move on to prisoner of
azkaban so
uh i don't know how much i'll end up
playing quidditch world cup i mean i i
kind of want to see
at least i want to win the quidditch
world cup
and probably at that point we'll move on
to prisoner of azkaban i have it it's
all ready to go
i actually am gonna have to play the uh
i'm not gonna be able to play it on
dolphin so
i use dolphin for
both chamber of secrets and quidditch
world cup because it just makes it look
so nice
but um
prisoner of azkaban actually doesn't run
all that well on dolphin so i'm just
gonna have to use a hard copy instead
plug up my nintendo wii to the capture
card and do the old-fashioned way so
whenever it runs well on dolphin it's
just so much easier easier to record and
then it also just
looks ridiculously good because you can
upscale it to 1080 and
buy anti-aliasing and stuff like that
[Applause]
all right so we got a 40 to 10 lead
right now looks like we're nowhere close
on the snitch
by the way guys i'm actually recording
this on september 16th
and for anyone out there who is looking
forward to hogwarts legacy you should
know
you should know the significance
of this day
i'll give you a second see if you can
remember
but uh one year ago
we got the official trailer
for hogwarts legacy and haven't heard
much of anything since it's very
unfortunate
some people were hoping man we were
holding out hope like maybe on the
one-year anniversary they'll have
something to say
but nothing at all nothing at all
so we continue to wait
if you guys missed
my latest video i have a video up about
the
wb
[Applause]
oh come on i gotta
try to make that shot go a lot faster
[Applause]
i just really don't understand the combo
system
i need to go through that one again
[Applause]
oh wow he still blocked it i was doing
pretty well with the combos right there
i feel like but
okay combo right there
messed it up i totally messed it up
all right this is looking a little shaky
so far
no i didn't want to throw to that one i
was trying to throw the top one
the middle quidditch hoop
yeah we talked a little bit about that
wb email that you know clearly says that
there is an update
coming on hogwarts legacy the question
is just you know when and
oh no oh no
oh they're doing their special move
no way
no way dude i do not like this
not fair
i wonder if there's no way to block a
special move
wow that's pretty cool
that's a pretty cool one i gotta say
i gotta say that was a pretty cool team
special
all right so it's 40 to wait 30 wait
what
wait
did they just get 20 points for their
special
[Applause]
why
what why do they get 20 points for a
special
i don't get it
let's throw this thing over there oh
they dodged it are you serious
no block come on block
there we go
[Applause]
there's nobody over there
i don't understand see it's like i
like i was pressing the far right right
there but what i'm clearly trying to
indicate are you serious another one
okay wait so they were 30 let's see if
this gives them two as well
[Applause]
no just 40. okay maybe i just looked at
it wrong or i don't know
yeah i was holding all the way to the
right clearly i don't want you just to
throw it to no one at all on the right i
want you to throw it to the person who
is most
uh right
yeah send a bludger after them
i can already tell how as you get
further and further those extra moves
are gonna be very very important like
right there like i'm pressing far left
i want you to throw it to the person on
the left side not like just completely
send it nowhere
[Applause]
there we go there we go
all right we still got a nice lead but
the problem with quidditch of course is
that
in close matches it's always going to
come down to the snitch
so if you botch that part somehow
then you're in trouble
no no no no no no no there
oh
here comes nice good job beaters
[Applause]
see sometimes when i tap it off the
combo it goes really fast just when i
tap it
and then other times it does that right
there where it's just like
now to get that one to go fast i'm just
holding down b like as i fire my shot
but sometimes you can get a quick one
off of the combo oh we're getting close
in the stitch
we're getting really close on the snitch
here
and we're up uh we're doubling them up
right now 80 to 40. like right there
what are you doing who is that even
going to
nobody's even in that area
oh here we go okay
time to get the snitch guys time to get
the snitch
stay in the middle stay in the middle
you got this you got this
keep control
oh yeah i do see the other person right
there with me though neck and neck the
other secret
[Music]
[Applause]
this was like f-zero or something
it's certainly a lot easier to stay on
here compared to the
harry potter games like the movie games
oh no
no no no no no no no
no come on drop it drop it
are you kidding me right now are you
serious dude i just lost
[Applause]
it's my first loss i can't believe this
i cannot believe this
germany wins
190 to 90. so it didn't matter that i
had the lead
didn't matter that i dominated the match
they just
grabbed the snitch right out from under
my nose now i'm curious to see what
happens from here like do i
i guess i continue i mean if i rematch i
don't know i don't know how it counts in
the standings if i rematch
maybe it like overwrites this one
i'm not for sure let's see what happens
here i kind of just want to play
organically and see if i can end up
winning that way all right let's see so
it does mark me with a loss right there
i have 400 overall points though still
dominant right there spain the only team
with more at 490.
all right so this is round three okay so
it does just move right on now we take
on japan
so we have got to get a win here our
backs are against the wall guys we
cannot afford
another loss here in this one
hello and welcome this is
back with you once again for another
quidditch match
all right we're off
oh dude look at this stadium man this is
awesome
[Applause]
i gotta say dude they just put so much
polish into the game like all the little
extras
like right now i don't see anybody open
so i'm just gonna shoot
my goal like i said from the very first
episode guys i just have to start trying
to score 160 every time i guess
and we are off to a hot start in this
one
that's 30 for team usa
and they are off to a quick lead over
japan here
[Applause]
oh oh oh
nice good job
beaters that person is wide open
oh nice block though
get him with a bludger nice we did
oh wow what a
stop
he's about to say steel wasn't really a
steal
there we go
yeah i was trying to combo right there i
just
the combo system
oh no no no no they're getting outfit
close good job
good save right there
oh another steal
no no no no no
we are not going to let the same thing
happen
it's okay our beaters are up for the
task today
all right we got somebody open right
there
nice okay
40 point lead let's go
what's the status of the snitch okay
nowhere close right now now we're
[Music]
[Applause]
closer by the usa's chaser
there we go
off the combo
so team usa out to a quick 50 point lead
make it 60 points right there off the
steel another just take it right back
from them
forget their combos
there we go
oh wow a special move for the steal
and we're off green
no no what would you throw to nobody
i don't understand
what
i'm right there why didn't i steal that
[Applause]
all right so 60 to 10.
and they just stole it from me
look for another bludger attack
nice
yeah you can tell like they're starting
to use the special moves more as well
no i tried to change it last second but
luckily it went through anyway
i'll take it
i will take it
all right so what is 70 to 10 again the
snitch nowhere close
being found right now
yeah your chances are so much better
like there's that hesitation when you
have to hold it down
but when you charge up the throw
it's just so much faster
if you just tap it the ball just kind of
hangs out there for so long just just
waiting
no no no no no no no here we go good job
all right let's fire it back
oh i was trying to do
my there we go
for a little speed
[Applause]
yeah it's like if
if no one has that little star indicator
around them like when you're trying to
pass then it just goes nowhere like
instead of the person just being able to
hold on to the quaffle
just kind of fires it nowhere oh are you
serious
we're going for a team special
i gotta figure out how to get my team
special i wonder if it has something to
do with the combos
oh dude wait did they just score twice
as well
[Applause]
let's see so they are 10 let's see what
it makes them now
dude that is garbage
oh my gosh so my eyes were not deceiving
me
[Applause]
on the other time
that was indeed a 20-point team special
which i
that just seems ridiculously unfair
right
that is not a thing
and quidditch
oh see i went for the quick one right
there
come on get it back
nobody open no no no no no no no
[Applause]
and you can't really pass or anything
when you're in the middle of the bludger
attack
oh i tried to change it last second
because i saw him slide over there to
block it
like they can tell where you're looking
at it
i can tell which hoop you're you're sort
of angling for all right we got a nice
lead though
130 but we're still not up enough
oh
dude they stole it right out from under
the goal
they're still not up enough to take the
snitch out of the
calculation here
oh dude
no i waited too late look this is not
it's just ridiculous is this just gonna
be a one pointer though
ten pointer rather i guess yeah okay
all right that's just ten fine fine fine
i really wanna know how i'm supposed to
build up my
specials
to get my little team special attacks
because in the first game when they
taught it to me dude it was like
popping every few seconds
no
dude if you hesitate at all right there
at the goal
[Applause]
there we go
okay so that right there it's just like
a defensive special though
i get the quaffle back but
not sure if i
no not that one that they're standing
right in front of
[Applause]
[Music]
let's try to get a combo here
[Applause]
there we go
dude i don't know like sometimes when
you're tapping in the combos to pass
like i just cannot get that little quick
pass to work
like when i first learned about the
combos it's something about if you if
you like you're holding l
and then you tap
that they'll do like a little quick pass
like nobody's open right there
[Applause]
who are you throwing to
jeez had to swoop in
got lucky right there i think
all right 120 to 140
and the snitch is getting closer dude
i'm going to be so mad if they catch the
snitch
if i'm up by like 140
imagine dude just imagine
nope
[Applause]
yes okay nice nice
oh dude
let's just get it back quickly before
they have time to use one of their team
specials
[Applause]
right quick score right there
that puts us up what 140 to 40. so we're
only up 100.
yeah i don't think we're gonna have
enough time to get up 150 before
the snitch shows itself
nice nice nice i don't know maybe we
will
[Applause]
oh no here we go all right i gotta focus
guys
i gotta do a better job than last time
she's very quick
oh no it's the in the goal
i think that's what got me in trouble
last time as i i must have gotten out of
the goal too much
[Music]
any other person caught up to me
come on we're so close let me grab it
let's go
all right a nice bounce back win right
there for team usa usa
[Applause]
victory
oh man it's definitely
i have definitely noticed an increase in
difficulty though that's for sure
i think
japan wasn't quite as strong as um
germany germany was really tough and
then even then i had a chance to win but
the snitch like i just made one little
mistake and
they
as soon as they got the edge on me that
was it so i wonder how many games you
play for the world cup
because that's our third game so let's
take a look at the standings here we're
at two and one and that is nice
australia
lost as well
so they are now wait what is wrong
why is spain 2-0 why have they not
played their third game
i don't get it but it's showing me at
the top of the standing so i'm pumped
about that at 700 points australia's
second at two and one with 550 but yeah
i'm not really sure what's going on with
okay looks like
i just noticed looks like spain germany
and france
they've all only played uh one game or
two games rather
two games
and so spain is two and oh
uh germany down there at the bottom is
one in one so they they actually lost
after beating me that first game
france's one and one the nordic team one
and two england one and two bulgaria one
and two wait why is bulgaria so high
then
i guess is it basing it on overall
points
now that i like
i actually like that because to me
overall points might be a better measure
of how
talented
your whole team is instead of just wins
and losses strictly because of how the
snitch works right because the snitch is
so
um just just the way that it counts for
so much
all right you know what i think we got
time for one more let's go let's do this
usa versus australia
both those games didn't go all the way
as long as they could the snitch came
out
well before well not well before on that
second one but
um before i had time to get
a big enough weed where it wouldn't even
matter
dude i am just so amazed at all these
different arenas like how many different
stadiums do they have this is awesome
like right there was a pretty good combo
all right off to the
[Applause]
let's just start with a bludger right
off the bat
right off the bat here it didn't work
though unfortunately
the beaters were up to the task
come on take that
take that from him
yes let's go
see i don't understand like
oh how did they stop that one i tried
that off the combo too
come on get it back get it back get it
back get it back
[Applause]
all right what's that 20 to zero
yeah but i've heard several people say
that prisoner of azkaban is actually
their favorite harry potter game
and i know i played it as a kid but i
just like that one just does not stand
out in my memories much i think maybe i
only rented it
i don't think i ever owned that one so
it's possible that i i didn't actually
make it all the way through the game
chambers though i owned that one and
just like played the crap out of it
just did so much in that game
let's go for a far left one over here
nice
[Applause]
all right 40 to zero let's just
completely demolish
just completely demolish the competition
in this one what do you say
no no no yeah don't even let them get
close
like right there i can't get the little
tap combo to work
[Applause]
nope nobody home
like all my teammates are suddenly not
in front of me
what i was trying to throw it at the
middle one
there we go
that's the hoop i was aiming for all
right a nice 50 point lead here
no oh they dodged that are you serious
[Applause]
pleasure coming at me
oh i did not think i reacted quickly
enough
yeah i don't think they're keepers as
strong
not as strong as germany in that first
game
he's blocking everything
but i don't think i was being as smart
with my shots either
all right 70-0
let's go right there
go
not really right there but i'll take it
i'll take it
i'll take it all right 80. we need 80
more points
i wonder if it would if it'll actually
let me get up that much or
the snitch would just always appear
before then
there's like nobody over here
nobody over here
man 90 points
team special move
let's go
[Applause]
gotta get it back
no what
what watch it take away my special move
now
watch it take it away
okay good it didn't
all right here we go team special
how about how about a 20-point team
special for us come on
dude that is slick
like the harlem globetrotters out here
oh i love it though
nice
oh it is gonna be are you serious
are you serious
a 20-point team special
taking us from 90 to 110.
basically negating the 10 points that
they got off their special
and then just another quick score for
team usa it's 120 to 10. right now we do
not see any sign of the snitch thus far
into the game
but team usa trying to make it to the
point where the snitch doesn't even
matter nice block right there and a save
by the keeper now team usa going the
other way here comes a bludger they're
gonna knock it out of the way trying to
get a combo going here
looks like they got it to somebody out
front they're gonna fire it into the
hoop now and it's defended
nice stop right there
by the keeper but team usa already has
the quaffle back again and they are on
the move nobody to stop him fires it
into the hoop on the left
and team usa is doing everything they
can to just make the snitch not even
matter
they are up 130 to 10 right now another
steal
far right there we go 140 to 10.
so they need two more uh scores
to be up by
three more scores to get up enough where
the snitch wouldn't matter but no
they're trying to score here they're
trying to make it so it doesn't matter
but another stop right there by the
keeper an incredible save and team usa
is coming back firing to the other side
looking for a score here gonna fart
gonna far
i was trying to say fire it to the far
right one but
it just came out far
all right going for the left one there
we go 150 to 10.
150 to 10 and we have caught a few signs
of the snitch here ladies and gentlemen
[Applause]
no no no no come on get up there
oh
i don't know steal it no
oh my goodness dude that's so annoying
all right 150 to 20 so we're only up by
130.
oh and another steal here let's get a
blood out here
let's get a bludger out here yeah you
guys are getting too many seals i don't
like it
i don't like it one bit
oh he almost got over there for the save
on that one
okay 160 to 20. we are up by oh 140
points right here
no no
no no no
they had their special guys
[Applause]
okay that's a pretty cool special though
i guess
australia i think right yeah pretty cool
special man and it's gonna be worth 20 i
just know it yep they hit it right back
oh no
oh no so they are trying to make it
where the snitch
basically is going to be the deciding
factor here
that makes it 160 to 40. team usa still
comfortably out in front
but australia is really picking up the
defense here another steal
usa gets it back
they're going the other way it's 160 to
40. usa was looking to put this one away
and then australia just came roaring
back there's another score for usa that
makes it 170 to 40. so they are up by
130 points at the moment
but they need two more scores to really
put this thing out of reach
there's one right there 180 for usa
and they go for another quick steal
speed boost flying to the other hoop on
the far right and that's going to be a
score for usa
190.
so 40 and that is a
150 point lead so even if australia
caught the snitch right now
they would only tie it
so usa doesn't have to worry about that
at the moment they're going to look for
another score though they want to make
it so it doesn't matter at all here they
get it back again
fires for the middle hoop and that is a
score usa now up
160 points
all they're worried about here is
holding off until the golden snitch
makes its appearance
they're gonna fire a bludger just to try
and keep australia from having any shot
right here
they are going the other way but it's
stolen by australia
and they're going the other way
now usa takes it right back this has
been a very strong defensive game here
in the latter half
team usa was dominant early and then
australia settled down they played much
better defense
but unfortunately for them team usa just
built up such a big lead
that it's been hard for them to get back
in it
easy score right there though
[Applause]
australia inches a little bit closer
that's 210 to 50 now
back-to-back steals right there one for
each team
usa looking for a combo
fires it for the middle hoop and scores
looks like usa has another special move
they are waiting to use
first they're going to steal it from
australia with a special now they're
going the other way here comes the team
special
let's see if they go for another 20
points here
and there's one score
right back through for another score
20 points for usa and they are just in
total control of this game here
here comes a bludger now heading for
australia
240 to 50 and at this point australia
not even concerned whatsoever about the
snitch
they have no reason to find it no reason
to look for it
because it is all usa
australia getting out in front over here
trying to get a goal but it's stolen
before they get a shot
here we go going the other way now usa
again and it has just been a
spectacular performance for them a truly
spectacular performance
right there though not a great throw
here we go usa threatening to score
again and they do man we could be
looking at a record here folks
260 now for usa
all the way down to only 50 for
australia usa's got it again
[Applause]
stolen before usa can get another shot
but they take it right back
and it's blocked again nice play by the
keeper there folks this is just getting
way
way out of hand at this point
and here we go
finally
the snitch has arrived and it's not even
going to matter so this is just all
practice
for usa here
because even if australia catches the
snitch it will not matter
this has just been such a dominant
dominant performance here
[Applause]
come on let's do this
yeah i don't even understand like their
meter over there on the right it's like
super small i'm not sure what that means
but usa wins again in just an absolutely
dominant
fashion
now let's go go ahead and take a look at
the standings because they should be far
and away ahead
on the point totals right now folks
usa wins and that's one quidditch card
to 50.
is your final score 28 goals in total
for usa that
is incredibly impressive folks
usa moves to three in one guys
thank you so much for watching i think
that's gonna be it for today
uh if you enjoy this video make sure you
give it a thumbs up before you go that
helps other people find it as always
thank you all so much for watching and i
will talk to you again soon